hey everybody is Charlie we're almost
there for our battle royale this is
going to be my episode 21 video careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
welcome back cody rhodes welcome back
dolph lundgren so they're putting all
the chess pieces on the board getting
ready for the finale but there are two
more episodes and there's a new round of
the flash ring giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video the episode was
all about dredging up the past Oliver
came to the realization by the end that
he needed to put the past behind him and
start living for himself Felicity had
that line in the episode and even though
it served as like the moral message for
the show I think they're stealth setting
up what the show is going to do going
forward
so every season he opens the intro with
my name is Oliver Queen
five years ago I was trapped on a
hellish prison and then he goes into the
diatribe about his father's mission to
clean up his city I think that's going
to change after this season because the
whole thing these past five seasons has
been Oliver living for his father's
mission and now if he's going to be
living for himself that means that the
mission is going to change a little bit
he's still going to try and clean up his
city but I think that's them stealth
saying that the core operating mission
of Team arrow is going to fundamentally
change after season five so let's do top
10 WTF comic book Easter eggs they've
built in a lot of really cool backstory
stuff too
but starting with number 10 Oliver gets
a dead body president from Prometheus
and when I saw the promo for the episode
I wonder if Prometheus had gone to the
island to find Oliver's father's remains
but it's just more Prometheus trying to
prove Oliver's missions based on a lie
his father lied he's trying to destroy
the foundation of what his mission was
built on and there was a lot of
foundation concrete in the episode so
you see how they work those metaphors in
there but number 9 the other big part of
the episode was in all the criminals
that have been prosecuted by Adrian
chase while he was prosecutor has to be
released because he's a psychopath so
that's actually a real-life thing if
there's like a criminal prosecutor that
puts a bunch of people behind bars and
it's found out that they did something
really terrible while they were doing
that then even if all those criminals
were guilty of the crimes that they
committed they'd still have to be
released so it's an opportunity to bring
back Cody Rhodes welcome back he got a
lot more dialogue in the
episode and I thought his performance
was way better too even though the
stunts that he did weren't quite as big
as the first time he came on but number
8 they fly back to the island they start
re watching all of her father's message
they watched it a couple times in the
episode I can't remember if that
actually showed up in the pilot or not I
need to go back and re-watch that
episode before the finale because the
end of the finale is going to sync up
with him hailing that boat with the big
Wookiee beard on and then it will pick
up with the events of season 1 but it
was such a nice Easter Egg them calling
back to how the Deathstroke masked with
the arrow through it God in the place
where it shows up during the pilot
episode so as Oliver explains it it
washed up on shore because Slade had
been wearing it when the Amazo boat blew
up so he thinks the Deathstroke is dead
right there and you have to remember did
that happen during the season two
flashbacks the second year that Oliver
was on the island but looking at the
timeline it's been about three years
since he saw Slade in this moment here
but then we learn about that during
season two in present day he basically
just swam to shore in the mirakuru just
kept healing him because he kept getting
bitten by sharks and fish that was
actually a lot of fun to hear about just
imagining Deathstroke swimming across
the ocean just because he had super
strength and super healing abilities but
number seven Thea is back so if you
think it's weird that Thea hasn't been
on the show for the last couple of
episodes they say that she only had a
contract for about 13 episodes of this
season and there's 23 total but number 6
they learned the secret about Oliver's
father he accidentally killed someone it
almost felt like they were going to turn
it into a bigger twist but immediately
Oliver's like that was an accident but
Thea keeps questioning it yeah he tried
to cover it up though so but wasn't
clear Robert Queen did a lot of terrible
things he was part of Merlin's
undertaking initially before he had
second thoughts and then Merlyn and the
rest of the group tried to kill him off
that was why the Queen's Gambit had that
accident Oliver and Sara were not
supposed to be on the boat but
Prometheus tried to add this level of
significance to everything blur like the
body that they found was actually buried
alive at a building that was named after
Oliver and then tried to release his
father's bioweapon the tuberculosis
weapon at a building named after Robert
Queen but number 5 we visit the island
there are four graves he only talks
about two of them his father's grave and
then Tiana's grave
the whole reason for going to Russia so
that's why they invoked those the other
graves belong to Yahweh and shadow and
they'll probably be invoked in the pilot
episode they always find ways to bring
them back and he was in the trailer as a
hallucination that Oliver was
experiencing so we will see Yahweh again
but it'll be a bit of trickery because
he still is dead in present day there's
no special twin like there was for
shadow but number four Anatoly explains
the plan which basically is Oliver
getting off the island in the first five
minutes of the pilot episode they said
he did a really good job when they were
filming that scene for the finale he
even gives them the wookie beard that
you see him wearing in the pilot just to
be more convincing like oh you've been
here for five years you're probably
going to look a little crazy the name of
the island they found me on is Lian Yu
it's Mandarin for purgatory I've been
stranded here for five years I've dreamt
of my rescue every cold black night
since then for five years I've had only
one thought one goal survive survive and
one day return home so if you ever
wondered why he looks like this now we
know he's just wearing a very elaborate
wig but number three team arrow stops
Prometheus's plan from releasing the bio
weapon they take down Samson it's badass
I love the way he walks up I'm gonna
thank you for making me the way I am and
just eats those bullets by putting his
arms up that is hardcore and
Prometheus's stand off was Oliver was
amazing I loved their scenes together
where Oliver just throws his father
abandoning him in his face he was going
to disown you no matter how bad my
father was at least he never gave up on
me so you don't really learn why he's so
willing to give up until he kneels down
which is very important for the twist at
the end when he's smiling inside his
cell inside Argus is where he wanted to
be he purposefully played into Oliver
his hand so Oliver believed that he had
broken him a little so even though it
seems like Oliver won Prometheus
technically is still in control because
like you said earlier this season I'm
ten steps ahead and you don't even know
what game were playing so number two
another game that Oliver doesn't know
that he's playing Kovar finds him is
he's preparing to leave you're going to
miss your boat so there's going to be a
big fight in the flash
with Cobra on the island in a big fight
with Prometheus everything between the
past and the present is converging on
the island in the last episode so it's
going to be really cool so there's going
to be a lot of craziness happening next
week but it's going to get even crazier
into the last episode as you would
expect but number one that final message
with Robert Queen Oliver finally gives
Thea the message he shoulda given her
years ago you're way stronger Oliver's
going to need to lean on you it's a
strong family moment the same way they
ended the flash episode this week there
was a lot of family in reaffirmation
going on we're like Barrie was having a
lot of fun because he lost his memory so
he's like I think I could be a superhero
it was sort of a way for him to reaffirm
his mission statement what it is to be
the flash what he's going to be doing
going forward Oliver is doing the same
thing I'm going to leave the past behind
me and start living for myself so the
cool thing about that though is that
implies fundamentally the mission of
Team arrow is going to change a little
bit so the way they opened the episodes
might change some of the dialogue in his
narration that's something that they
would put in the comic-con trailer so
maybe the producers will announce
whether or not they're going to change
the intro in a big way going forward in
season six but like I said is prometheus
is sitting there in Argus smiling to
himself watching Oliver give that press
conference yeah my father did some bad
stuff but he also sacrificed his life
why don't we all work towards a better
future in Star City for our sons and
daughters and you know Prometheus is
just chuckling to himself he's inside
Argus who else is inside Argus right now
well we know king shark is in there
because we're going to see him next week
on the flash we know that black siren is
in there as well
it in the trailer that they released she
is out and going after Quentin in the
new Black Canary so it seems like he's
going to bust out pretty quickly but let
me know in the comments what did you
guys think of the episode what did you
think about the special guest appearance
of Robert Queen they had to shoot this
new maybe they shot this when they were
doing the big four night crossover stuff
and they had the actor back knowing that
they would be using this later but it is
nice even though the plot of flash niro
are very different they're sort of doing
a lot of the same things to matically
like having the heroes reaffirm who they
are what their mission is this is how
I'm going to be a better superhero going
forward a lot of you were asking why
Oliver didn't wear the green arrow
costume through most of the episode in
like he says that's mostly because he
was doubting the core operating mission
that he was on his father's mission so
after he decided to put
the past behind him and start living for
himself that's when he put the costume
back on but I know a lot of you are also
asking about vigilante
where is vigilante they just disappeared
so they said that that character would
be big in season six and they would not
unmask them whether it's a woman or a
man whoever we won't find out till
season six and yes I did see that
Malcolm Merlyn John Barrowman said that
he would not be back to the show in
season six that doesn't mean they're
going to kill him off but there are a
couple people that are supposed to die
in the finale so he's definitely higher
on the list but my other big question
what's your big death predictions for
the finale two characters are supposed
to die they said most of all so I'm
assuming just two but there could be
more but what's going to happen next is
is they confirmed that there's going to
be a Deadpool TV series that will drop
in 2018 on sxx they said it would be an
adult series so it's not going to be
like a kid's cartoon but I'll explain
what's going on with that there's new
spider-man homecoming footage and then
there's that brand new x-men show gifted
there's a teaser for that so I'll try to
get all those videos out as fast as
possible but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Lucas C please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for all that you
can click here for brand new flash and
you can click here to learn all about
Ghost Rider coming back on HSN shield
for their finale next week thank you so
much for watching that's at five I'll
see you guys tonight